le rôle de la télévision est d'informer
de distraire mais aussi de cultiver la
culture ce n'est pas toujours drôle mais
nous sommes là non pas pour rigoler
c'est notre mission de service public et
c'est pourquoi sont présents sur ce
plateau jacqueline maillan et pierre
palmade
j'ai lu sur mon horoscope ce matin il se
peut que des invités surviennent au
moment inopportun n'en fait pas une
maladie fait les patientes et je dois
dire que vous n'y étiez pas vraiment
invitée mais vous êtes des amis d'hervé
bourse donc nous avons été contraints de
nous incliner alors jacqueline maillan
dans quatre jours c'est la première à la
comédie des champs elysées de l'autre
côté de la rue de la première pièce de
pierre palmade pièce montée avec donc
vous jacqueline maillan comme unique
interprète
c'est donc une pièce à petit budget
alors je vous laisse hélas quatre jours
ça commence mardi et ses débuts une
grand aventure comme nous tous un peu le
trait tout de suite une question sur
jacqueline merci d'avoir répondu
rapidement
pourquoi ce titre pièce montée d'abord
est-ce qu'il est bien monté
basset et des rues seulement qu'ils
avaient pensé à j'ai pensé à ps monte
parce que j'étais le c'était le thème
c'était l'anniversaire quoi donc on
craint pas une
le titre et du gâteau que finalement la
pièce montée très bien alors c'est donc
une pièce avec des partenaires invisible
je raconterai rapidement l'intriguent
jacqueline maillan vous attend pour
fêter son anniversaire douze invités qui
ne viendront jamais et donc vous
soliloquer comme on dit dans les salons
en exprimant un peu vos fantasmes
alors question jacqueline comment s'est
passée cette rencontre avec pierre
palmade et de piquant draguer vous les
petits jeunes vous a réservé deux
rencontres et jacqueline au début et
c'est vrai que j'ai fait savoir quoi et
bobards un jour c'est tellement dit
qu'elle la suite on s'est rencontrés
puis on sait plus et puis bah la pièce
est écrite et nous voilà embarqués pour
la voie en vous demandant jacqueline
d'être un petit peu plus court dans vos
réponses je voudrais vous demander quel
ressentiment vous éprouvez en voyant ce
magnifique spectacle de la flamme
olympique traverse son pari elle est là
est-ce qu'il ya une angoisse
existentielle d'être seul sur scène non
parce que
vous savez j'ai l'habitude d'être seul
avec moi-même donc je transmets sort du
chiqué comme si ce n ayant pas faire
lorsque vous n'avez pas répondu tout à
l'heure avec question depuis quand vous
avez vous les jeunes gens et comment
s'est passée cette rencontre mais moi je
n'avais pas du tout l'intention de
draguer un jeune homme est ce jeune
homme est tombé dans les bras avec
beaucoup de chaleur et vous savez ce que
c'est bon je n'ai jamais eu d'enfant
savent ou croient plus au modèle lors
donc vous êtes seule en scène pendant ce
gala lundi sur ce je me racontais ma
part je pense ce soit vers 4h20 oui sans
entracte
mais on vend des coussins et des
sandwiches non je pense qu'on fera une
heure et demie parce qu'il a écrit très
serré moi je parle vite maintenant on va
faire une heure et demi oui je pense
qu'est ce que ça donne une répétition
pierre ça vous feriez vous will have
been travail mais moi je suis alors de
spectateurs quoi c'est mon rêve de gosse
qui m'arrive quoi mais pas que pour être
sérieux un instant je crois que s'il ya
des années et des années que vous êtes
un grand admirateur de jacqueline c'est
un peu votre enfant de lui
c'est une pièce donne envie de faire ce
métier et la fiche qu'elle en paraît en
ce moment mais je l'aï rêvé depuis très
très longtemps quoi est bon même si on
est donc travers l'action quand je
m'arrête cinq secondes je réalise que
ben c'est c'est vraiment un très très
belle aventure dans laquelle je suis
embarquée que je suis je suis fier
d'avoir pu à jacqueline parce que je
vais le dire que c'est un joli cadeau
qu'il me fait il se trouve que sa
génération est la mienne nous avons la
même façon d'aborder le sujet avec
humour
avec un peu de tendresse quelquefois
énormément de tonus alors nous nous
sommes très bien entendus
si je viens informez vous allez
travailler aussi avec josiane balasko
année mais plus tard aussi vous voyez ça
ça roule pas mal d'accord alors je vais
vous demander un petit service parce que
je suis un petit peu fatigué mais samedi
je ne devrais plus
l'envié comme on dit le sujet suivant
vous adresser à la caméra qui est la
numéro 3 mais ils avalent trois ans mais
moi il faut des lunettes
la formation jacqueline mayo si vous
d'abord un événement d'une portée
géopolitique considérable il ya près de
20 ans la première visite d'un président
américain en chine communiste c'est
aujourd'hui un opéra qui met en scène
cette vision l'homme qui fait chanter en
tout bien tout honneur
mao nixon sean l'ail est un américain de
34 ans puis de cela ce passionné par les
images d'actualité et surtout parce
qu'elle cache reportage pascal deschamps
et bernois puis sro a tout de suite